bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
peace be with you I'm Eddie your host
and you're watching the Deen show my
next guest who's gonna be with us in a
second to talk about why when he
accepted the truth he ended up losing
not only his wife but his house his
guest house and much more he's gonna be
sharing his experiences with us
so you all can take the good from it and
it can help you endure some of the tests
and trials and you might be going
through you don't want to go no we'll be
right back to talk with our brother dr.
Lawrence Brown be right back on the Deen
show
Oh
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
why did that maybe it maybe it's just to
break the ice
Salameh come how are you dr. Brown very
good thank you hamdulillah Oh slow down
he said something Arabic now would you
say
uh-hum did Allah all praise be to Allah
dr. Brown our audience really enjoyed we
got some positive feedback on your show
that we did on how you accepted this
wonderful beautiful way of life the
truth that is ordained from the creator
of the heavens and earth as practiced by
over 1.5 billion people from all around
the globe the fastest growing way of
life in the world today people got to
benefit from your story how have you
been since the last time we've seen you
Oh again o hamdullah know every things
are good things are good I'm keeping
busy I'm still writing I'm still working
I guess in these days that's a good
thing we really want to thank you and
I'm sure the audience wants to thank you
also for coming back again I hear on D
so happy to be here ok dr. Brown the
world now knows that you former military
major doctor surgeon at that has
accepted this way of life the truth that
all the messengers of God lived Noah
Abraham Moses Jesus Christ in the last
and final messenger sent to mankind of
problem have a peace be upon they all
live this way the way that calls you to
surrender your entire self to the
Creator the one God in Arabic we call
him Allah to surrender yourself to his
will to strive to be the best human
being that you can be to be in a
constant state of self-development
self-improvement doing all the good that
he's called you to do you've accepted
that truth but now there'd been some
hardships talk to us about some of these
hardships that you had to go to through
and endure well actually yesterday I was
just at a conference where I was asked
this question
I I told my conversion story and in the
question and answer period somebody
asked what what happened after you
converted was it easy was it hard what
happened and so I kind of went down this
laundry list of difficulties because I
think it's the typical experience when a
person becomes Muslim they face some
difficulties after I became Muslim
within a period of one year my now
ex-wife divorced me took took my
children into her custody took my house
wealth and I dare I say certain amount
of my happiness and then at the same
time there there was just a difficulty
in the transition so my friend my
parents took it very hard they they
basically severed communication with
with me and disinherited me and I
remember one particular communication
where they just they just told me by
letter they didn't want to see me they
didn't want to hear from me they didn't
want a phone call they didn't want a
letter they they they basically just
didn't want anything from me any
communication at the same time the the
people who I had hung out with before my
friends basically deserted me I was no
longer the fun person in their minds
that that I had been before obviously
being most of my wasn't into what they
were into I wasn't I wasn't into the the
the drinking the dancing the party and
etc and that was a change for me and so
so basically they deserted me
my job was no longer compatible with my
faith and the end
I had to leave I was in the military I
was I had been in the Air Force for well
let's see now it would have been twelve
years at that point I just signed up for
another four years and and so I found
out during that period that really I
didn't feel that my faith was compatible
with being in the military
III effectively became a little bit of a
pacifist and here I was in this in this
war machine that that I simply could not
reconcile with with my faith so to make
a long story short within a period of
one year I lost my parents my friends my
wife my children my house my wealth I
went from being a successful doctor to
still being a doctor but in in pretty
straitened circumstances dr. Brown
should people who accept Islam expect
these hardships someone might say well
I'm coming to the truth why all the
hardships oh yeah first of all I think
you should accept expect some hardship
whenever anybody comes to Islam they
need to expect some hardship and I think
that is the price of sincerity it's the
price and the proof of sincerity look if
it were a party everybody would be doing
it it's just like any of the other tests
of sincerity and religion prayer fasting
paying charity making pilgrimage all of
these things are things where you take
from your time from your wealth from
your energy from other things you you
can be doing to get down get down on
your knees and into prostration and pray
five times a day to to take time off
from eating and drinking too fast for
the pleasure of our Creator to to pay
from your wealth to benefit other people
who who need it more
to make pilgrimage taking taking your
vacation time and your money to go and
do something for the pleasure of our
Creator instead of going and hanging out
on the French Riviera or some other kind
of vacation all of these all of these
things are things that you take from
yourself as a testimony of your faith
like I said if it was a party everybody
would be doing it but for those who are
seeking seeking Allah's reward in the a
para meaning the hereafter there's a
there's how can I put it a price to pay
yeah something something something that
you have to you have to expect to put
forward for for the for the hereafter
and when you become when you become
Muslim it can be easy for most people
but one thing I've noticed is that in
general in general converts to the faith
find themselves tested in the beginning
my own impression is that that is a test
of sincerity because I've seen people
I've seen people pass that and I've seen
people fail that iíve seen converts to
the religion go back to disbelief
because the tests they faced after they
became Muslim were greater than they
felt they could bear and it was really
sad I mean I've seen people go back from
faith for four piddly little things that
you you would just you just think I mean
how could a person throw their faith
away for that very sad but so bottom
line yes when you become Muslim expect
to be tested expect expect to have to
show some some strength show some
patience and and endure this test
because because truly anything that you
leave for the pleasure of Allah he will
replace with something better and and
Allah tells us in the Holy Quran in a
Melua story you Sarah after hardship
comes ease
I just described my hardship or a part
of it there was a lot more to it than
that because after I got over that hump
there there were other hardships that
came along but as I said I lost my wife
Allah gave me another wife i remarried
and I have to say I am happier with my
second wife that I ever was with my
first home did he laugh something he
laughed
alhamdulillah I you know I lost my
children from my household not from my
heart they're in my heart and I hope
that I'm in there is we we still get
together for vacation every year we
still see each other but Allah gave me
another child by by my new wife I lost
my house in America I now live in an inn
you know a better situation in the holy
city of Medina
alhamdulillah I lost my friends some of
my family alhamdulillah Allah gave me
the family of Islam which is worldwide
and which I mean I can honestly say you
never feel a brotherhood you know you
never really know what brotherhood is
until you're in the brotherhood of his
mom I have one brother no sisters just
one brother he also became Muslim what I
can tell you is he and I are constantly
reminding each other of the fact that we
were never brothers we were never
brothers until we became brothers in
Islam you know we were fighting we were
each other's throats we saw each one we
saw the other one as somebody who kind
of blocked our desires or maybe we were
just at each other's throats until we
became brothers in Islam when we became
brothers in Islam then we knew what
Brotherhood really was I told you I lost
my wealth when I when I became Muslim I
used to live in a country I don't know
if you could really call it in a state
but I mean it was a house on acreage out
in the country I used to tell people I
didn't have a guest room in my house if
I had people visiting I didn't have a
guest room I had a guest house I had a
second house on the property
that was for guests that's the that's
how nice the layout was and that's what
I lost I went from living in that
circumstance to living in a pay by week
studio apartment in just I mean a really
bad area of town you get you know you
you would you you didn't want to go into
the elevator to go up to to the floor
because you know people were urinating
in the elevator but the stairs weren't
any better you take the stairs and you
practically had to hold your nose
because people you know the people were
urinating in the stairwells as well it
was that bad that's a look pay by the
week I mean you know what pay by the
week means in America I mean where do
you where do you find where do you find
a rental apartment that's paid by the
week alright we're gonna hold it right
there we're gonna take a break and we'll
be right back for more with dr. Lawrence
Brown here in the Dean show no speech is
better than to do that was call people
to Allah and to do there were no
speeches better you know nothing is
better than that is it true that if one
person I'm the Allah giving you an
ability to guide someone there's a lost
permission the creator's permission that
is better than everything in this world
but in the whole world and everything
that's in it in another narration it's
better than the best of wealth but if we
really felt that Eddie would we not be
giving out giving job and this is
something that we encourage all the MSAs
all the dowel organizations the mustards
forget this we want to create more we
give these to the novices for free for
free for free we want our brothers
so even yourself being in such a
respected field as a doctor you also
endured a lot huh yeah you know I mean
it's easy to look at somebody who is in
a respected field like as a doctor who
has a respected income and so on and you
don't think that they can fall too far
you know but there's this old saying
that what counts is not how far you fall
but how high you bounce but but that
doesn't mean you don't fall I mean at
that time I was saddled with very heavy
lawyer expenses because of the divorce
you know I had just received a
restraining order from my wife telling
me I couldn't go with and I forget but
it was something like a hundred yards or
five hundred yards of her of my children
of my house and so on and so forth and
this all because you know I mean all
just for a no-contest divorce she had
just gone in and said she wanted a
divorce and they said what for is he
beating you is he mistreating you and
they said no no or she said no she said
no I just want out and they said well
what's he doing and she said nothing
nothing I just I just want a divorce
that's all so it wasn't it wasn't like I
had any history of being a violent
person or or doing anything bad she just
she just went to the court and got a
restraining order on me I had to just to
see my children the court made me hire a
security officer to protect my children
from me for me to see my children when
the court started to allow me to see my
children even though by my wife's own
admission I was a peaceful person I
never I never did anything to to warrant
a divorce just she wanted out she was
Catholic
I had become Muslim she just she wanted
out that was enough you weren't a cool
guy anymore to take around to the social
wine-tasting parties yeah what could I
say I was no longer the the fun guy I do
I used to brew my own beer before I
became Muslim okay look I'm sorry to say
but yeah I used to brew my own beer
one of the things after I became Muslim
that my father complained about was that
he missed my beer not me my beer didn't
say he missed me said he missed my beer
now you know it was a hard time it was a
bit of a crazy time and and you know I
wasn't the best example of a Muslim at
that time I don't I don't blame my
parents for for their reaction because
because they saw me go from the person
they knew to a person they really did
not know or understand and at the same
time with the media representation of
Islam in the West it creates a lot of
fear and uncertainty in people's hearts
and when you see this happen to a loved
one whether it's your son as was the
case with my parents or your husband as
was the case with my wife it you know it
bends people's minds and it takes it
takes time for them to come to realize
that you may have changed your religion
but you yourself may not have changed
that much how did you grow your hair in
a funky way start listening to rap music
get tattoos would you dress different I
mean what made you such an outcast to
them no I didn't really dress
differently but but it was just a series
of things you know when you become most
of them you clean up your act you you
you know you stop going to you know you
stop going to dances parties you stop
associating with you know with alcohol
I'm not saying you stop drinking I'm
saying you avoid places even where
alcohol is dry and drunk okay but fruit
juice apple juice pineapple non spiked
is okay huh well of course haven't you
you know so many other things that you
know are good for you and and but but
alcohol is out so you know you you stop
going to social circles where alcohol is
served you you know you're no longer
that hug your neighbor kind of a guy you
know because you don't you don't even
shake hands with women anymore you don't
shake hands with your neighbor's wife
how about a kiss on the cheek
baby look you know I know this is a
shock to a predominantly Christian West
where you know you go to a wedding
ceremony and you dance with the bride
and you kiss the bride and you and and
all other thing I mean the garter belt
scene and all this stuff but look the
bottom line is we're talking Christian
West Christian
what does Christian mean follow the
example of Christ show me anywhere in
the Bible where Jesus Christ touched a
member of the opposite sex outside of
his family please
show me that it didn't happen he was an
Orthodox Jew Orthodox Jews to this day
do not do not touch women outside of
their family or if you're a woman they
don't touch men outside of their family
I mean we know this was his code of
contact and conduct because when we say
Jesus what do we sometimes say rabbi
Jesus he was an Orthodox Jew this was a
code of conduct that was respected
throughout the Abrahamic faiths it's
only in modern times that our customs
have bent it out of shape according to
the desires of the people Schwimmer note
on that dr. Brown isn't this a high
sense of respect given to the woman when
in today's society men are trying to do
whatever they can to grope up on a woman
and get a cheap feel here and there
where in Islam we don't have a right to
touch what's not ours
someone get offended some people will
get offended if you touch their car I
mean women are more precious to us than
our cars or any material goods so isn't
this a respect towards the woman and her
husband action is it is it an article of
respect not to touch a woman yeah it's
an article respect to her it's not
article of respect to her husband to
respect that this woman is for this man
and you don't you don't you know you
don't interject yourself into that in
the least a little bit but look don't
ask me this question ask a woman this
question Islam is the fastest growing
religion in the United States is the
fastest growing really
in the world and most of the converts to
religion to Islam the majority of the
converts to Islam are women not men so
you know we we hear these popular
sayings that Islam is a man's religion
if Islam is a man's religion why are
most of the people converting women not
men it's because it's because they see
that the rules of Islam instead instead
of constraining them the rules set them
free
now that's that's difficult for people
to understand and it's best explained by
a woman but it is the fact after hearing
this jihad struggle because jihad is
what it means is to struggle after
hearing about this struggle that you
went through should people be worried
about scared about accepting this truth
you know what I can tell you is I don't
I don't regret anything I wouldn't
change anything
I've been Muslim now for about 15 years
I can honestly say I never gave up
anything for the pleasure of Allah
except that he gave me what was better
and you know an important point is that
with all of what I described that I went
through despite going through the
divorce losing my kids in my family lose
losing my friends my and my parents and
so on
the problems at work the the problems
with the prejudice and everything else
the one thing I haven't told you is that
during that period of time when I was
facing all those trials and tests I
remember that time as some of the best
days in my life all I can tell you is
that Allah filled my heart with peace
and satisfaction and showed me what was
really a value showed me that this dunya
meaning the material aspects of this
life this dunya is nothing it's nothing
compared to living upon the path of
truth living upon the path
the religion of our creators design when
when you submit to Allah and you submit
all of your actions to his pleasure you
find that he gives you a level of
satisfaction that makes everything else
seem insignificant and over time step by
step you find that things just come back
to you as I said I don't blame my
ex-wife and my parents not completely in
any case for what happened because they
saw the change in me they were suffering
the concerns that they had from how the
media portrays the Muslims and and it
they couldn't think straight they
couldn't think straight in their
circumstances
my wife was worried that you know I
would abscond with the children and my
my parents thought we're thinking the
same thing etc etc but you know with
time they came to know me again my
parents and I are back on good terms my
ex-wife and I are you know able to
communicate in a polite respectful way
my children as I said they've always
been you know we've we've always been
together by telephone and vacations
every year and and and my life
circumstance improved in so many
different ways one that one thing I can
just say from this experience is anybody
out there anybody out there who
perceives the truth of Islam and wants
to embrace Islam do not be afraid for a
second do not be afraid of what you will
lose do not be afraid of what you will
face do not be afraid of the trials and
the hardship just pray to Allah to make
it easy for you to give you patience to
give you strength to bear it not to not
to test you beyond your ability to bear
and to bless you with abundance therein
because I can just I can guarantee you
from my experience from the experience
of other converts I have known I can
just guarantee you that after you become
Muslim
Allah will will fill you with such a
sense of internal richness that you will
realize that everything that you valued
before Islam was for nothing can you in
short define for our non-muslim audience
for our brothers in humanity who we want
to become our brothers in faith use some
Arabic words can you define for them
Islam Muslims Allah what this means
let's start with Allah Allah is the name
of the Creator if you go to the Holy
Land you will find that the Arab Jews
the Arab Christians they are Muslims
they all refer to God as Allah this is
the name that they knew our Creator by
in the holy land and remember these are
the people who are the descendants of
the the lineage of the prophets okay
they are the ones whose forefathers walk
to earth in the company of the prophets
they should know you look in the Bible
and you find in the Old Testament that
God is referred to as a low elo aah
hello now does that sound more like God
or does that sound more like Allah
hello he's also referred to as Elohim
which is the plural not the plural of
numbers but the plural of respect plural
of respect being a literary device a way
of showing respect through through words
okay so in any case in the Bible you
find God called hello I think it's a
hundred and twenty-eight times and two
thousand five hundred times two thousand
five hundred times called
Elohim with an IM at the end again what
does that sound more like God or Allah
so that's Allah Muslim is more Islam a
person of Islam Islam being to submit to
to Allah so Muslim is a person who
submits to to alone brother Brown dr.
Brown thank you very much Allah the
creator of the heavens and earth rewards
you for being with us and and you and
thank you for inviting me once again to
the Deen show I sent out money Carla
come Salam
what up intellectual better got to and
that was our brother dr. Lawrence Brown
thank you brother for being with us and
everyone who has taken the time to watch
this now I hope you got to benefit from
his experiences we're all going through
tests this life is a test but what's 10
20 30 40 50 years or maybe a day or two
days after you watch this or maybe you
can go outside right now you might get
hit by a car
you don't know death can sneak up on you
at any time so is it worth it that you
live according to your whims and desires
and you chase the dollar that man that
woman and you make that your main
priority you forget about your purpose
in life nor do you even ask and I'm not
talking about asking Joe the car
mechanic or Trisha the hairstylist I'm
talking about asking the one who created
you the one who created this whole
universe and everything in it the one
who Jesus Christ called upon the one who
submitted himself as all the prophets
submitted themselves to God including
the last and final messenger sent a man
kind of problem having peace be upon him
they all called upon the one who was all
knowing all merciful all loving they
called upon him for guidance and
direction the Creator the one God in
Arabic Allah so we call upon him and we
ask him to help us and to guide us and
to help us through the hard times and
the struggles we want to show that we're
sincere so we don't want to be
you know we had a bad day or maybe
something came along that we had to
implement the prayer might be getting in
your way no no no no no no no we revolve
all revolve our life around Islam we
don't try to plug Islam in so whoever
you are out there it's tough it's not
easy life is a challenge with or without
Islam you're gonna be going through hard
times but with Islam being on the right
direction
you got your creators help and for every
hardship that you go through God
Almighty will recompense you he will
take care of you he will reward you and
you'll have that peace and tranquility
as dr. Brown did you see for someone
else that might have went through this
people lose their houses and wives all
the time for other things but he went
through this for his krater Allah
replaced it with something better and
gave him the strength to endure and the
patience and at the end we have nothing
less than paradise if we stick to this
way but what do you got if you go to the
grave and you didn't live life according
to how your Creator wanted you to live
you lived it according to the society or
culture that you live in there might now
be calling you to good it might be
calling you to evil so we have to be
striving to be the best that we can be
according to God's will not our desires
and take from this story and try to
stick straight and strong to the right
way the right direction his life is
short it's a test all right
nothing to it but to do it and we'll see
you next time here on the Dean show
until then I said I'm alaikum peace be
unto you
oh he created